so sieht ein check von aus auf dem weg
richtung innenstadt das ist ein platz
hier durch den russischen panzer rollen
mit russischer soldaten durch wüssten
wenn sie es denn schaffen und wenn sie
in hmb innenstadt wollen aber die
menschen sind vorbereitet wir sehen hier
sogar schon bereit stehen für weitere
molotow man vorbereitet es gibt auch
schon einige ihn vorbereitet sind und
hier
freiwillige momentan kontrollieren sie
in autos
was passiert wenn russische panzer ihr
auf diesen check point zurück ich höre
fragen
gibt
also sie haben einen plan sagt er dass
die anzahl nicht durchkommen werden
die
branchen armin kann er sich in die
russische armee
wir werden nicht weggehen wir werden
bleiben wir werden mit unseren waffen
kämpfen das ist unsere stadt erst unser
grund sagt victor witschel die news
group newspapers
weiß nicht aber
darum geht es mir
möchte hier bleiben wir müssen hier
bleiben und wir müssen uns verteidigen
er sagt viktor
paul vielleicht für unsere zuschauer zur
erklärung wir schalten ja jeden tag zu
dir manchmal stehst du dort mit
schutzweste und helm jetzt hast du
keinen helm auf im moment bedeutet das
dass die situation im moment
nicht so gefährlich ist oder du sie im
moment so einschätzt
ja es hat jetzt mehrere stunden kein
alarm gegeben ehrlicherweise werde ich
bin nach dieser schalte hier aus
sicherheitsgründen gefahren auf wieder
ein helm aufziehen aber man muss auch
ein bisschen sensibel sein so einer
situation so was denn winkler steht hier
den ganzen tag ohne helm kann keine
schutzweste hat und da fühlt man sich
als reporter auch manchmal einfach
schlecht wenn man hier wie man steht ja
keine schutzkleidung hat so wie wir aber
tatsächlich ist die bedrohungslage sehr
unterschiedlich dann wenn es luftalarm
luft drinnen gibt man sich draußen
befindet sollte man sofort einen keller
aufsuchen beziehungsweise seine
komplette schutzkleidung anlegen und
auch wenn man weiter hier richtung ihr
team kehrt das ist der ort wo weiter
heftig gekämpft wird nur mit helm und
schutzkleidung vor allem wenn man ja
leider liefert oder raketeneinschläge
paul im hintergrund bei dir sieht man
auch ab und zu noch autos fahren was
sind das für menschen die jetzt noch auf
der straße sind ja und was ist dein
eindruck wie viele menschen sind noch in
kiew
die minister zum einkaufen irgendwo raus
müssen oder menschen abholen wollen das
ist kein vergleich mit einem normalen ja
aber natürlich gibt es hin und wieder
ihre autos die hier durch müssen zum art
etwas besorgen jemand aussuchen ein
notfall es geht ja darum auch dass trotz
des sieges irgendwie dieses leben
weitergehen muss aber viele bringen sich
auch in den autos weiter in sicherheit
sparen richtung bahnhof abfahren von ihr
über die verbliebenen straße in richtung
west bernd du sprichst ist unter der
eingeblendet tag 14 in putins krieg wenn
wir mal eine zwischenbilanz ziehen in
diesen 14 tagen zwei wochen schon dieses
grausamen krieges du bist in kiew die
ganze zeit wie würdest du sagen hat sich
die stadt verändert
die stand ist zu einer geisterstadt
geworden schon von anfang an und dennoch
ist es eine stadt des widerstandes eine
stadt der sich gegen juden stellt ich
bin gestern bei vitali klitschko gewesen
habe ihn auch die frage gestellt ich
gerne viktor gestellt habe man kann es
so weit sein dass russische soldaten
hier stehen das sind und er hat mich
entgeistert angeschaut und gesagt
niemals niemals werden ihr in der
innenstadt russische soldaten seien das
pforzheimer in kiew an einem checkpoint
zwischen in dem vorort von kiew und der
hauptstadt ihr vielen dank